[Music]
my lab develops optical imaging methods
and microscopy methods to look at the
living brain and then we use them to
study lots of different aspects of how
the brain works I'm a physical
volcanologist which means I study all
the physical processes and control
volcanic eruptions and what happens to
the materials that come out of a volcano
after they come outside I first met in
at a data science institute event on
data visualization I gave a presentation
and I talked about my new fast 3d scape
microscope and how it generated tons and
tons of data and there were all
different ways of looking at that data I
presented a lot of results on
neuroscience samples and I thought this
would be billion for Volcanology and for
looking at the microstructure bubbles
and crystals and how they all interact
so I pushed there and we wrote a grant
together and got funded I've always
found volcanoes fascinating and of
course I want to learn what a nut wants
to learn but the question that we're
interested in answering is is
understanding the way in which materials
flow when there's a mixture of bubbles
and solids inside of those liquids and I
trained as a physicist and I really
appreciative of anything in the world
where we're trying to understand the
fundamental principles that kind of
govern the properties of these more
complex systems so to understand how it
will kind of curve up so how it evolves
you need to have an understanding of the
physics and the chemistry that controls
it and some of these processes are super
big and some of the fossils happen at
the very small scale and and all this
knowledge is going into computer
simulations for example where we say
under these conditions will this volcano
erupt but we need to know what types of
physics to put in their models and this
can only be done by doing experiments
and getting the observations to put into
these models in my lab we use lasers and
optics to try to gather information
about living tissue and the thing about
living tissue is that it's alive and
it's moving and
it's got a lot of dynamics to it and so
we tried to build imaging systems and
microscopes that could go really really
fast and then because we were imaging
the brain we needed to image deep into
the brain so we needed to do 3d imaging
the idea for escape came about over like
a 10-year period we we were doing lots
of different methods and we came up with
this kind of really weird way of
collecting images that in the beginning
we didn't even know if it was gonna work
but as things developed gradually you
know we realized it was a microscope and
we started some collaborations with
people who had small things that they
wanted to image in 3d like fruit flies
and crawling and fruit fly larvae and
then you know it grew from there and
more that we realized it could do we
expanded its capabilities we expanded
the things that we wanted to image using
it the experiments run by a postdoc from
Volcanology and a graduate student farm
engineering and they put together the
instruments one is making the mixture
the other setting of the microscope and
then the images before we started with
them small experiments we also had
students in the lab working together to
test different materials test different
processes that they can then miniaturize
and put in the microscope this project
is certainly rekindled my childhood love
of volcanoes and geography I took my
kids to the lamont-doherty open house
earlier last year and we worked with i
net to look at you know how lava flows
down the hillside and it reminded me of
my honeymoon in Hawaii and recently I
took my kids to Yellowstone and had
great fun explaining to them all the
different processes that lead to all the
different volcanic rock formations and
so on so I've got really excited about
it again and it's really fun to feel
like all microscope is actually
contributing to our fundamental
understanding of that